During the war at Marineford, Blackbeard
rocked one of the core beliefs of the one
piece world when he gained the power of a
second devil fruit. And this game-changing
power made Blackbeard one of the absolute
strongest characters in the world. But have
you ever wondered what might happen if
LUFFY got to eat a second devil fruit as
well? And what fruit would be the PERFECT
combo to pair with his original powers?
Well, I figured the ABSOLUTE BEST options and
the first fruit that we are going to explore
as Luffy’s second power is one of THE MOST
POWERFUL devil fruits in the entire story.
But it’s not the overpowered Magma fruit
or the even insane abilities of the Law’s
Operation fruit. So which one is it? Well,
let’s kick things off with the Venom fruit,
which is an amazing complement to Luffy’s
rubber abilities, and you will see why in
just a second. But this fruit was originally
eaten by the Warden of Impel Down, Magellan,
and it has unbelievably strong abilities that
are absolutely perfect to pair up with Luffy’s
current powers. And in case you forgot, this is
a Paramecia type fruit which allows the user to
produce different kinds of poison. During the
Impel Down arc, Magellan shot out deadly venom
hydras, traveled quickly through Venom Roads, made
giant clouds of poison gas, and even unleashed
this terrifying Venom Demon which could literally
melt through the entire underwater prison.
Now you may be wondering why I have chosen this
one as the first option for Luffy’s second fruit,
so let me explain. Imagine if we gave Luffy just
a stupidly overpowered devil fruit to combine
with his rubber fruit. Maybe something
like Admiral Kizaru’s light fruit. Well,
I could imagine that Luffy wouldn’t use his
rubber powers as often since the light logia
fruit is simply a godly power. So instead
of just combining two super powerful fruits,
I wanted to pick devil fruits that truly
complemented his previous abilities. Plus
we have already discussed how powerful
Luffy would be with other devil fruits,
but giving him a second devil fruit ON TOP of
his regular one is a completely different beast.
Now, I’m also going to assume that Luffy
has his second devil fruit powers from
the start. Maybe he randomly ate a second one
by accident, although it is equally possible
that he could have eaten a second one after
Blackbeard showed that it was possible after
Marineford. Either way, he’d have plenty of
time to master his second devil fruit powers.
Which is why the Venom fruit is an absolutely
perfect combo power for Luffy because he can
still keep his main fighting style of punches,
kicks, headbutts, but now he can coat his body
with deadly poison so that each of his attacks
deal WAY MORE damage than before because
this venom this fruit produces is absolutely
deadly. STRAIGHT UP, if you touch this stuff,
it is basically an instant death sentence. Not
only that but having Venom on his body would also
be a huge defensive boost since enemies would not
want to touch him at all. He could also use some
ranged attacks like these crazy poison gas balls
that Magellan uses during his first clash against
Luffy. On top of this he could travel insanely
fast around the massive prison using the venom
roads and he could use gigantic poison attacks
that could take out entire groups of enemies all
at once, which would have been perfect during
battles like at Marineford or Fishman island.
So CAN YOU IMAGINE JUST. HOW. POWERFUL. this would
make him? His base form would be ridiculously more
powerful than in the original story.. And there
are a few specific examples where the poison would
make Luffy’s life much easier, in particular
when he gets into super long battles like
the epic twelve hour clash against the mochi man
Katakuri or the Emperor Kaido. For these fights,
Luffy could build up poison damage over time,
which if you’ve ever played a game like Pokemon,
you know that a poison buildup can kill you
just as fast as a single massive attack,
so the longer the fights go on, the weaker Luffy’s
opponents would get. Another example of this power
making a fight way easier is against the string
fruit user Doflamingo because Luffy’s deadly
poison could easily melt Doffy’s strings
before they even have a chance to cut him.
And just imagine how insane Gear 5 poison
man Luffy would be. There are so many
crazy things he could do by combining
his limitless imagination and venom,
such as making sticky venom balls
to throw all around the battlefield,
or if he awakened the venom fruit as well,
then he could make the entire environment
a poisonous AND bouncy minefield that would be
absolutely impossible for enemies to fight on.
However, there are some downsides to this
fruit for Luffy. First, just like Magellan,
Luffy might get some poison in his food which
would send him straight to the toilet for a
whole different kind of battle. But even more
importantly, Luffy doesn't like to kill people,
and this deadly poison would definitely lead
to more deaths than in the original story.
So unless Luffy can make a poison that
just knocks out or paralyzes opponents,
then this actually isn’t THE PERFECT
second devil fruit for Luffy.
Which is why the Brain fruit might be even
better for Luffy. Because I think we can
all agree that Luffy is pretty much an idiot
outside of battle. But if he could learn and
remember all of the incredible things
he experiences throughout the story,
he would truly be a genius in the world.
Seriously, he has the world’s best navigator,
helmsman, engineer, swordsman, musician,
cook, and archeologist all on his crew,
so if he could learn from each of them, he’d
be a literal genius. Plus he might stop getting
tricked all the time, although, now that
I’m thinking about it, I wonder if Luffy
would actually have to read for this fruit to
work. So… nevermind. Brain fruit in the trash.
But before we get to the next absolutely
insane second power we could add to Luffy,
we first need to clarify that we don’t know if it
is possible for Luffy to eat two devil fruits. We
were told in chapter 385 by CP9, that eating a
second devil fruit would make that person’s body
explode. This is possibly because the spirits of
the fruits couldn’t live together in one body,
but we don’t really know for sure. That’s why
it was so surprising when Blackbeard showed us
that he could use both the darkness fruit and
the Tremor fruit at the same time. However,
there are lots of theories about why he can
do this, for example, his special logia fruit
or that Blackbeard might actually be more
than one person. But I also think it would
be hilarious if anyone could eat two devil
fruits and that the rumor was false all along.
So back to Luffy. Now we are going to
take our normal rubber straw hat captain,
feed him this devil fruit, and watch as he
evolves into… Chop Chop Luffy. And to show
you just how MINDBLOWINGLY perfect this
power would be for Luffy, let’s go back
to this scene at Marineford where Mihawk is about
to slice Luffy into swiss cheese. Luckily though,
Luffy throws Buggy in front like a shield, and
the clown tanks the blow. But in our new scenario,
Luffy doesn’t even need his Buggy shield, since
his Chop Chop powers literally make him immune
to damage from any type of blade. Slashes?
Nu-uh. Cuts? Goodbye. Even overpowered bites
or anything sharp like spikes are now ABSOLUTELY
USELESS against Luffy. And this is HUGE for the
straw hat captain since these types of attacks
are one of the main ways that he is seriously
injured in the story, like when he was stabbed
by Crocodile and Katakuri or when he gets bitten
by Rob Lucci. But this incredible defense
isn’t the only upgrade to Chop Chop Luffy,
because now he can pretty much fly as we see
Buggy do many times throughout the story. However,
he can only use this ability as long as his feet
stay on the ground. The author of One Piece even
drew us this diagram to demonstrate how it works.
However, with Luffy’s combined powers, his range
might extend even further than Buggy’s since
he can stretch his body further. And honestly,
I can see so many creative ways for Luffy
to attack if he can separate his arms and
legs that he could simply overwhelm enemies
by attacking from so many different angles.
Plus the ability to fly could help the
crew scout, which would have definitely
come in handy during the Skypiea arc when
the crew was lost in the jungle. Luffy
might also have been able to climb back up
to the arc maxim much easier, which could
have meant Enel wouldn’t have been able to
even summon his strongest attack. Although,
Luffy might get more distracted since he
can fly around, and there is the obvious
weakness to kicks in the balls. However,
there is one big disclaimer for this fruit,
which is that we don’t know if this fruit is
weak to haki or not. For example, if Mihawk
coated his blade with haki, could he damage Buggy?
If so that would be a major nerf for this fruit,
but we aren’t really sure since we’ve never seen
a clear example. Though we are explicitly told
he is immune to all blades, so there is a good
chance haki blades still don’t affect this fruit.
Which you might disagree with, but no one can
disagree with how perfect these next fruits
are for Luffy. And these are so overpowered
for Luffy that they surpass simple fighting
power and take Luffy to the next level of
overpowered. That’s because I’m talking
about the Biscuit fruit and the Cook fruit,
which were both introduced during the whole
cake island arc. And since both of them allow
the user to make an unlimited supply of food,
Luffy will never have to worry about going hungry
again. Which is undoubtedly a perfect power for
Luffy since he has such a bottomless pit for
a stomach. Kinda just like how you are the
perfect person to subscribe to the channel
for more one piece content just like this.
But even unlimited food is not the best power up
we can give Luffy, because this next devil fruit
is going to take things to a whole new level.
That’s because since Luffy fights with flying
punches, ax kicks, and slamming head butts, there
is no greater power boost than simply giving him
more arms, legs, and heads to fight with. Which
means that Nico Robin’s Flower fruit is simply
the greatest second devil fruit that Luffy could
eat. ADD MORE EXCITING BITS AND GEAR 5 SECTION
Don’t believe me? Well, keep in mind that this
fruit allows the user to make copies of any part
of the user’s body and place them anywhere within
a certain range. WHICH IS SUCH AN OP ABILITY,
especially for Gear 5 Luffy as we will see in
just a second. But there’s even more because for
fighting there are endless attacks that she uses
by sprouting limbs. We have the famous Clutch,
Slam, and even super sized versions
of these attacks. These powers are
also great in a supporting role since
Robin can make copies of her eyes and
ears to spy or combine her limbs into things
like nets and wings, which allow her to fly.
And for Luffy these powers would
ABSOLUTELY take his fighting style
to GOD-TIER level. He instantly has
more arms and legs to fight with,
so with his rubber he could surround enemies
with a storm of punches and kicks that would
CRUSH any fighter’s endurance. Kinda like how
Katakuri made extra mochi arms to completely
pummel Luffy back on Whole Cake island These
powers would also allow Luffy to get around much
easier since he could fly across islands or swing
his way through tight places like in Impel Down.
But that’s not even the ultimate ability of this
fruit, because the final power up that Robin
showed us in Wano might even allow Luffy to use a
famous technique from another ultra popular anime.
That’s because Robin’s strongest ability allows
her to literally make normal or giant sized clones
of herself to fight against opponents. So just
imagine Luffy busting out the Shadow Clone Jutsu
to make a ton of copies of himself. This would
especially be useful in brutal fights against
some of the strongest pirates in the world,
such as when he battles Kaido. I mean can you
just imagine a hundred advanced conqueror haki
fists slamming down on the Emperor? That fight
might have been over before Luffy ever unlocked
Gear 5. And especially if Luffy could combine
his clones with his other gear techniques,
then Luffy would be nearly unstoppable,
though he’d have to increase his stamina quite
a bit to keep up with that many powerful clones.
Plus just imagine having multiple Luffy’s. MAN,
IT WOULD PROBABLY BREAK THE WORLD! I can just
picture one giant Luffy throwing down lightning
bolts on Kaido while ANOTHER giant Luffy rains
down firey punches. With these two powers
combined, he would be an UNSTOPPABLE GOD.
However, even though the Flower fruit is
undoubtedly the best fruit to pair with
Luffy’s original devil fruit powers, that
doesn’t mean that this version of Luffy is
the strongest we could imagine. Because I have
to admit that seeing Luffy flying around as a
giant Red Dragon is just such an awesome idea
that I made a video about what would happen
if Luffy ate each of the Yonko fruits instead of
his own. And you can watch that video right here.
Shanks for watching and I’ll
see you in the next one.